und jetzt das heute journal
windsurfer richter und christian sievers
guten abend hinein nach dem spiel ist
wie immer vor dem spiel und vor was für
einem das steht jetzt schon fest gegen
england in wembley selbst wer mit den
absatz regeln auf kriegsfuß steht weiß
dass es nicht einfach ein fußballspiel
es ist ein klassiker mit diesmal ganz
besonderen bedingungen das deutsche mal
so mal so team gegen eine england elf
die bei dieser wm
bei dieser em entschuldigung nicht
begeistert aber funktioniert dominik
löschmeister jetzt über folklore- und
vorfreude auf die ko phase
herr rigo auf geht's die deutschen sind
wieder da englands medien laufen sich
warm für den fußball klassiker am
dienstag wohl kaum ein gegner ist bei
den engländern so gefürchtet wie die
deutschen offenbar werden wir immer von
deutschland rausgekickt es wird ein sehr
schweres spiel werden
ich bin immer für england aber leider
glaube ich dass deutschland gewinnt in
dieser saison spielen sie ganz weit oben
wir haben ein gutes team aber ich glaube
sie sind nicht stark genug und
deutschland hat gute spieler im
legendären wm finale 1966 fiel das
umstrittene wembley tor
die engländer holten ihren ersten und
bislang einzigen titel
danach gewannen sie nicht mehr in einer
ko-runde gegen deutschland wm 1990 auch
1996 bei der em im eigenen land mal
wieder elfmeterschießens aufgeht schießt
und köpke hält diesmal soll es anders
werden in wembley premier siegesgewiss
also sicher das englische team wird
brillant abschneiden nur mit
allergrößter mühe und viel glück hatte
die mannschaft von bundestrainer löw
gestern abend den nervenkrimi gegen
außenseiter ungarn überstanden
leon goretzka rettete das 2 2 und damit
den sprung ins em achtelfinale
das team brennt auf den england
klassiker
er stehe nach recht was wir gehört haben
nach dem spiel wir sehen doch nach dem
spiel gegen england in wembley
das ist das schönste was man sich
vorstellt ich freue mich gigantisch
drauf spielen dann auch noch in england
gegen england in so einem geilen stadion
ich glaube viel mehr geht nicht
deutsche fans werden es schwer haben das
team zu unterstützen
tickets gibt es nur für deutsche mit
wohnsitz in großbritannien
obwohl sich die delta variante weiter
ausbreitet sind 45.000 zuschauer in
wembley zugelassen
gerrits aufgeht der elfmeterschütze von
96 ist heute übrigens trainer der
engländer und will keine extra schichten
fürs elfmeterschießen angst haben sie
nicht vor den deutschen aber großen
respekt auf jeden fall das spiel gestern
abend hat folgen über den sport hinaus
die regenbogenfarben durften zwar nicht
in der münchner arena erstrahlen ihre
symbolik aber ist gerade deshalb
plötzlich sehr präsent und ein
ungarisches gesetz das vorgibt
minderjährige schützen zu wollen indem
es materialien über homosexualität und
transgender in schulbüchern zensiert ist
heftig in der kritik als diskriminierend
grundrechtswidrig eine schande
dieses gesetz ist in ungarn vergangenen
nacht in kraft getretenen parallel zum
fußball spiel sozusagen regierungschef
viktor orban verspricht sich davon
rückenwind und einen propagandaerfolg im
eigenen land das könnte ihm gelingen auf
der anderen seite gibt es viele
ungarinnen und ungarn den ihre regierung
zu weit geht
es lohnt sich also wie immer mal genauer
hinzusehen aus ungarn berichtet für uns
britta hilpert
kinderkirche orban wähler in der
kleinstadt weder ist die welt noch in
ordnung könnte obama seinen gesetz gegen
pädophilie und homosexualität ist hier
willkommen
er will ja spende auch das
heterosexuelle prinzipien in der
gesellschaft vorherrschen sollen meint
andrew witty und homosexualität
unterstütze er nicht dieses gesetz ist
nur gemacht um die kinder zu schützen
meint christina ich stehe dazu in
ungarns klassen soll die
gleichwertigkeit sexueller
orientierungen nicht vermittelt werden
kinder sollen hier keine fragen zur
homosexualität oder geschlechter
identität stellte das neue gesetz ist
teil von orbáns nationalkonservativen
programm stärkung der nation der
christlichen familie
es ist die logische folge der neuen
verfassung von 2020
gleichgeschlechtliche ehen schließt sie
aus geschlechtsumwandlungen ebenso
familie das heißt die mutter ist deine
frau
der vater ein mann viele eltern viele
wähler sehen das genauso dass er so
turin
das neue gesetz ist ein
kinderschutzgesetz dazu sagen in ungarn
soll es nicht passieren dass eltern eine
idee haben über sexuelle aufklärung und
dem kind da etwas ganz anderes gesagt
das war die schädel der regenbogen teil
ungarns konzentriert sich in der
hauptstadt kürzlich protestierten hier
tausende gegen das umstrittene gesetz es
polarisiert die gesellschaft weiter
meint der mann der bei den wahlen im
nächsten jahr als stärkster konkurrent
sein könnte die orban regierung ist ein
instrument der macht das immer gegen
jemand kämpft
das kann die eu sein oder der liberale
märz im schloss die einwanderer die
obdachlosen und jetzt ist es die
sexuelle minderheit es leuchten in
ungarn auch gebäude und stadion aber nur
in den farben der ungarischen nation
es ist ein jetzt erst recht gefühl orban
hat sein ziel erreicht
die menschen in ungarn sind übrigens
europa fans konstant um die 80 prozent
zustimmung zur eu sie suchen und finden
dort wohlstand und stabilität
die eu ist aber mehr sie ist vor allem
anderen vor milliarden- subventionen und
brüsseler bürokratie gebilden zunächst
mal eine union die auf gemeinsamen
werten fußt bzw
fußen sollte und die beinahe verzweifelt
nach wegen sucht wie sie mit denen
umgehen soll die diese werte nicht
teilen denen sie egal sind die sie
bekämpfen
heute ist eu gipfel und der kommt an
diesem thema nicht vorbei gunnar krüger
aus brüssel
brüssels bunte botschaftern einen ganz
bestimmten gast kann nicht verbergen
die stadt zeigt flagge die
staatengemeinschaft tut sich schwerer
wenn die chefs zum gipfel schreiten
prangt die bunte fahne nur am revers
die rodder das ungarische gesetz ist ein
rückständiges gesetzt europa ist ein
klub mit regen
du kannst nicht sagen ich will das geld
aber die regeln die gehen nicht nichts
an
und doch war ihm genau das bislang
möglich viktor orban lässig auf europas
laufsteg ein gesetz dass homosexuelle
diskriminieren soll sontra wird so ein
gesetz haben wir nicht wir haben 1 das
rechte von kindern und eltern schützt
will er darüber reden das steht nicht
auf der agenda
und doch sprechen fast alle das thema
bei orban an 16 von 27 unterzeichnen
einen aufruf für respekt und toleranz
folgen vorerst keine
mit orban hat die eu einen störenfried
im haus und mit putin einen vor der
haustür
russland steht zur stunde auf der agenda
nicht nur weil alexei navalny hinter
gittern sitzt sein fall zeigt nur erneut
die eu braucht dringend eine russland
strategie frankreich und deutschland
hatten dafür einen vorschlag mitgebracht
wie antworten wir geschlossen aus die
provokation und wie können wir
vielleicht auch gesprächsformat die
herstellenden konflikte kann man am
besten lösen
das hat man am amerikanischen
präsidenten gesehen wenn man auch
miteinander spricht neben sanktionen für
ganze wirtschaftssektoren wäre also auch
ein treffen möglich so wie es beiden und
putin hatten aber die baltischen staaten
warnen bitte nicht nachmachen noch nicht
wegrennen der semmel fest steht nur die
sprache der macht und er sieht den
zugeständnissen ohne gegenleistung nicht
eben ein zeichen der stärke
seinem strength raum der freiheit so
sieht sich brüssel als statt
die staatengemeinschaft muss aber auch
mitmacht sprechen nach außen und nach
innen
der konflikt um die rechtsstaatlichkeit
unabhängigkeit der justiz freiheit von
medien da sucht eine eu nach antworten
die sich lange nicht vorstellen konnte
oder wollte dass sie auch mal die
finanzieren würde die sich gegen europas
wertebasis stellen
anne gellinek unten amt nach brüssel wie
könnten denn diese antworten aussehen
heute auf dem eu-gipfel so richtig gute
griffige funktioniere funktionierende
antworten hat die eben nicht weil man
sich bei der gründung nicht vorstellen
konnte dass es mitgliedstaaten geben
würde die die grundwerte verletzen würde
was es gibt sind sogenannte
vertragsverletzungsverfahren die sind
genau so sperrig wie sie klingen
langwierige prozesse vom ogh an deren
ende dann geldstrafen stehen die haben
auch im falle ungarn schon mal gewirkt
aber sie dauern eben sehr lange was es
auch gibt ist ein rechtsstaatlichkeit
mechanismus der letztes jahr beschlossen
wurde
aber der greift eben nur bei der
veruntreuung von eu-geldern also
schnelle griffige antworten hier von der
eu fehlanzeige
und dann andere gibt es noch eine große
europäische frage nämlich wie umgehen
mit russland
da haben deutschland und frankreich
jetzt eine idee quasi zum den e auf den
gipfel tisch gelegt eine idee die in
diesen in diesen minuten von den 27
staats und regierungschefs und chefinnen
diskutiert wird und eine idee die
spaltet merkel und microm haben den
vorschlag einer doppelstrategie gemacht
sie wollen einerseits eine härtere
gangart für die europäer sie wollen
wirtschaftssanktionen vorbereiten damit
man das nächste mal wenn es eine
störaktion der russen gibt schnell und
geschlossen reagieren kann und
andererseits stellen sie aber auch die
möglichkeit von hochrangigen eu russland
gipfel wieder in den raum also 27 plus
putin
diese idee sorgt für streit die
osteuropäer und die balken können damit
überhaupt nicht klar kommen sie sagen
wie putin muss erst bedingungen erfüllen
bevor wir uns wieder mit ihm zu einem
gipfeltreffen und merkel wird auf diesem
vielleicht ihrem letzten gipfel wieder
mal zu beweis stellen müssen wie ihre
fähigkeit kompromisse zu schmieden wie
es darum bestellt ist sagt anne gellinek
live im brüstet anderen vielen dank der
wohl letzte eu gipfel für
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel davor
heute morgen ihre wohl letzte rede im
parlament dem sie seit 1990 seit dem
jahr der deutschen einheit als
abgeordnete angehört keine meldung der
nachrichtenagenturen vergisst diesen
historischen aspekt der
regierungserklärung heute zu erwähnen
nur eine geht darauf nicht ein die
kanzlerin selbst ein abschieds tag im
bundestag der zum schaulaufen wird für
die die merkel nachfolgen wollen heike
slansky auch an diesem tag bleibt sich
angela merkel treue minutenlanger
applaus hauptsächlich aus den eigenen
reihen der ihr fast unangenehm scheint
sie mag ein wirbel um die eigene person
auch wenn das heutzutage gegen jeden
trend und zeitgemäß wirkt politisches
lob ist ihr suspekt sie haben in den
vergangenen 16 jahren
ihre kraft und ihre intellektuellen
gaben stets uneigennützig in den dienst
deutschlands und europas gestellt aber
der reihe nach das schaulaufen der
nachfolger ist im vollen gange jede
bühne ist willkommen armin laschet ist
eigens angereist annalena baerbock lässt
sich diese gelegenheit nicht entgehen
botschaft wir unter uns anschließend
zieht merkel bilanz in ihrer wohl
letzten regierungserklärung mit einem
bekenntnis zu europa wenngleich die
pandemie schwächen aufgezeigt hätte wir
wissen heute dass wir das besser können
und jetzt auch in zukunft besser machen
werden
deshalb sehe ich insbesondere in der
krisenreaktion im gesundheitsschutz bei
schengen und im binnenmarkt die bereiche
in denen wir über eine stärkung der
europäischen handlungsfähigkeit
diskutieren müssen die ard lässt kein
gutes haar an der politik der regierung
europa mache sich erpressbar wenn wie
von merkel gefordert der sogenannte
migrations pakt mit der türkei
verlängert würde
der schlüssel zur eindämmung der
illegalen migration nicht aber nicht in
ankara
er liegt in berlin hier werden mit den
höchsten sozial höhe versetzen menschen
auf die gefährliche überfahrt gelockt
migration klima corona themen die der
profilschärfung der spitzenkandidaten
dienen mal staatstragend mal kämpferisch
laschet knöpft sich die afg vor es ist
eine lebenseinstellung weder von einem
tödlichen virus noch von anti
europäischer helm und skepsis und es
recht nicht von populisten und
nationalisten lassen
wir uns dieses europa kaputt macht wir
brauchen eine deutschen bundesregierung
die mit vollem herzen europäische
politisch und klimaneutral wir müssen
verstehen dass europa nur stärker wird
wenn wir es politisch begreifen wenn
dort mehr politik gemacht wird
europa ist nicht nur ein binnenmarkt es
ist eine zeit der veränderung und des
abschieds merkel wie gewohnt unaufgeregt
in sonst so aufgeregten zeiten so und
jetzt ein urteil mit erheblichen folgen
im nachrichtenüberblick mit server es
dürfte sich auf hunderttausende
pflegekräfte pflegebedürftige und deren
angehörige auswirken
konkret geht es um meist ausländische
kräfte die im haus der zu pflegenden
wohnen laut bundesarbeitsgericht haben
sie anspruch auf den mindestlohn und
zwar auch in den zeiten in denen sie nur
in bereitschaft sind
daran müssen sich auch ausländische
arbeitgeber halten
geklagt hatte eine bulgarin die sieben
tage die woche rund um die uhr für eine
90-jährige da sein musste aber nur für
30 wochenstunden bezahlt wurde
schauen wir auf die krone situation in
deutschland da bereitet die besonders
ansteckende delta variante zunehmend
sorge so mahnt bundesgesundheitsminister
sparen alle reisenden zur vorsicht sie
sollten sich sorgsam über das
infektionsgeschehen informieren test
angebote annehmen und quarantäne
pflichten ernst nehmen
das sagte er dem handelsblatt laut dem
robert-koch-institut hat sich der anteil
der delta variante die dritte woche in
folge verdoppelt auf 15 prozent
bahnreisende müssen vorerst nicht mit
streiks der lokführer-gewerkschaft
rechnen allerdings kündigte gdl-chef
weselsky um so massive reaktionen ab der
zweiten augustwoche an
bei einer entsprechenden urabstimmung
werde eine breite mehrheit für streiks
stimmen zeigte sich weselsky sicher für
das scheitern der tarifgespräche machen
sich gdl und bahn konzern gegenseitig
verantwortlich
als erster bundesminister hat peter
altmaier in washington vertreter der
neuen us regierung getroffen
unter anderem den sonderbeauftragten für
klimafragen john carroll
danach zeigte sich altmaier optimistisch
dass man wieder enger zusammenarbeiten
werde auch bei handels- und umwelt ihnen
fragen dazu beantwortet der
wirtschaftsminister später im heute
schon ein update in der kanadischen
provinz saskatchewan sind die überreste
von hunderten kindern gefunden worden an
einem internat für junge ureinwohner
erst ende mai hatte man gräber in
british columbia entdeckt auf dem
gelände einer ähnlichen einrichtung bis
in die 90er jahre hinein wurden solche
um erziehungs internate von der
regierung finanziert indigene kinder die
oft ihren familien entrissen wurden
sollten sich dort der christlichen
europäischen kultur anpassen
ihr alltag war oft von gewalt und
missbrauch geprägt
hongkong war immer ein experiment eine
stadt die ihren bürgern freiheiten
garantieren sollte von denen sie im rest
chinas nur träumen konnten
eine stadt in der sich reden und
streiten ließ demonstrieren und drucken
und nebenbei gut geld verdienen
dieser tag heute wird so sieht es jetzt
aus marl als tag in die geschichte
eingehen
an dem das experiment endgültig vorbei
war die letzte große stimme für freiheit
und demokratie in hongkong gibt auf sie
musste aufgeben
ulf röller über eine zeitung die zuletzt
noch einmal eine million exemplare
gedruckt hat und ab morgen dann 0
es kommt nur noch selten vor dass
menschen nachts schlange stehen um eine
zeitung zu kaufen aber für viele in
hongkong ist apple daily
mehr gewesen als die tägliche lektüre es
ist die letzte freie stimme der stadt
die an diesem abend für immer verstummen
wird es eindeutig dass es das ende der
presse und meinungsfreiheit
das ist die letzte ausgabe deshalb bin
ich hier mein vater hat mich schon als
kind die zeitung greift im
blitzlichtgewitter wird die druckfrische
ausgabe ausgeliefert mit einer
millionenauflage die schnell vergriffen
ist
may hat nach ihrem studium bei apple
daily angefangen wie viele ihrer
generation die von freien und
unabhängigen journalismus trocken
dieser traum ist jetzt geschichte ich
will nicht auf wiedersehen zu meinen
lesern sagen aber wir haben keine wahl
wir müssen wir hoffen dass die bürger
hongkongs nicht aufhören zu kämpfen
drinnen in der redaktion machen sie sich
mut der in tränen zu ersticken droht
denn sie verlieren nicht nur ihren job
sie müssen auch um ihre sicherheit
fürchten
im letzten jahr holte die polizei ihren
boss gemini ab denn nun im gefängnis
sitzt weil er die peking treue
machthaber in hongkong kritisierte seine
letzten worte damals jetzt passiert es
das war erst der anfang seitdem hat es
viele festnahmen gegeben und die konten
von apple daily wurden gespannt die
staatsmacht ist auch an diesem abend
wieder aufmarschiert damit niemand
vergisst wer in hongkong das sagen hat
aber diesmal war sie nur gehen sie
auseinander sie verstoßen gegen das
versammlungsverbot
auch pekings machthaber warnen gleich
die ganze welt
hongkong ist ausschließlich eine
angelegenheit chinas kein land und keine
organisation haben das recht sich
einzeln ischen apple daily wird niemand
mehr retten aber seine macher und viele
hongkonger bürger wollen trotzdem nicht
ihre zuversicht verlieren
es gibt diesen spruch die sonne wird
wieder aufgehen
ich hoffe eines tages sind wir wieder da
und dann leuchten die leser von apple
daily ihren zeitungsmachern zu als ein
zeichen der hoffnung
die sonne ging an diesem abend in
hongkong nicht auf aber wenigstens ein
licht eine mutige statt die unter
unvorstellbaren druck geraten ist für
alle welt zu sehen
hongkong hat sich sehr verändert sagt
einer der bei apple daily als politik
reporter arbeitete die leute fühlen sich
als bekämen sie keine luft mehr kann
sollte jetzt noch mal hier mit weiteren
nachricht und da schauen wir auf das
neue klimaschutzgesetz das nun den
bundestag passiert hat und mit dem
deutschland bis 2045 klimaneutral werden
soll
damit setzt die regierung eine forderung
des bundesverfassungsgerichtes um 8
milliarden euro wie sie zusätzlich in
den klimaschutz stecken und das alles
dürfte es sicherlich auswirkungen auf
die deutsche wirtschaft haben frank
bethmann an der frankfurter börse ja
ganz sicher denn mit den geldern werden
die photovoltaik windkraft und
wasserstoff technologie gefördert zudem
fließen mittel in die landwirtschaft und
die gebäudesanierung das ganze im
prinzip ein weiteres konjunkturprogramm
doch mehr noch als um wachstumsimpulse
geht es darum das klimaschädliche co2
nicht mehr in die atmosphäre zu blasen
und so gibt es nun strengere vorgaben
demnach müssen die co2-emissionen bis 20
30 statt um 55 jetzt um 65 prozent
gesenkt werden bis 2040 soll sich der
ausstoß dann um 88 prozent reduziert
haben um schließlich bereit 20 45 und
nicht erst 20 50 die klimaneutralität zu
erreichen
und wie so häufig den 1 ist dass immer
noch alles viel zu wenig und zu
unkonkret
und die anderen sehen ihre felle
davonschwimmen zb die industrie was
genau kritisiert die am neuen
klimagesetz naja die sagt es reicht
nicht klimaneutralität per gesetz
vorzuschreiben
dafür braucht man eben die unternehmen
zu einem erheblichen teil und immer
anspruchsvollere zielvorgaben und
verkürzte fristen würden dafür nicht
ausreichend sondern man müsse eben ernst
nehmen was da machbar ist und was die
unternehmen dafür bräuchten die
industrie das lässt sich daraus hören
fordert weitere finanzspritzen
die brauchte der dax heute im übrigen
nicht er geht ordentlich aus dem handel
mit einem plus von fast 0 9 prozent
danke frank und vielleicht spiegelt sich
beim dax auch wieder was das münchner
ifo institut heute bekannt gab
nämlich dass die stimmung in der
deutschen wirtschaft überraschend gut
ist nämlich so gut wie seit november
2008 10 nicht mehr nach dem start darin
blicken vor allem gastronomen händler
und dienstleister positiv in die zukunft
einigen branchen machen allerdings
materialengpässe zu schaffen
das wetter ist auch heute nicht ganz
ungefährlich der deutsche wetterdienst
warnt aktuell vor schweren gewittern in
teilen von bayern und baden württemberg
dabei können auch starkregen und hagel
runterkommen in der nähe von miami ist
ein 12 stöckiges wohnhaus teilweise
eingestürzt dabei kam mindestens ein
bewohner ums leben
die zahl der toten könnte aber noch
deutlich steigen denn die rettungskräfte
gehen davon aus dass noch menschen unter
den trümmern liegen nach dutzenden
möglichen bewohnern werde noch gesucht
das wohnhaus wurde in den 80er jahren
gebaut warum es mitten in der nacht ein
stürzte ist noch unklar
die meisten tier und pflanzenarten macht
der klimawandel schwer zu schaffen
der so genannten uralte eiche kann er
offenbar nichts anhaben sie ist der
stolz der gemeinde ivenack in
mecklenburg vorpommern und das wohl
größte lebewesen deutschlands mehr als
30 meter hoch auf brusthöhe fast zwölf
meter umfang zwischen 800 und 1200 jahre
alt stand also schon hier während der
kreuzzüge im mittelalter
sie ist wie üblich für diese bäume innen
komplett hohl nur 20 bis 40 zentimeter
dick ist die äußere hülle
dennoch wächst sie weiter und erfreut
sich bester gesundheit
vor allem trotzt sie mit den vier
anderen ivenacker eichen hohen
temperaturen und der dürre aber wie
schaffen diese uralten bäume das und was
können wir von ihnen lernen
bernd mosebach mit antworten ein
ziemlich dickes ding diese ivenacker
reiche dieser methusalem unter den
bäumen europas
meter für meter erfolgreicher widerstand
gegen unwetter schädlinge und den
menschen
in 33 metern höhe gipfel dieses
meisterwerk der natur in einer mächtigen
krone
eine von fünf eichen die alle um die
1000 jahre alt sind mitten in
mecklenburg stehen sie manche mächtig
angeschlagen und vom blitz getroffen
verwundet und doch irgendwie nicht
totzukriegen 100.000 naturfreunde
streifen jährlich durch den wald von
ivenack hellen andrews und ralph häcker
vom forstamt stavenhagen kümmern sich um
die anlage alles durchhalten die können
sich ja nicht bewegen die sind an einem
platz und da müssen sie mit klar kommen
egal was passiert witterung und so
weiter und wie die einfach funktionieren
finde ich total spannend und was hier
alles hier schon gesehen haben dass die
eichen überhaupt noch stehen verdanken
sie nicht zuletzt ihren früchten im
mittelalter nutzte der mensch ihrer
eicheln zur schweinemast
hier wachsen sie auf lehmigen boden der
feuchtigkeit speichert ihre weit
verzweigten wurzeln zapfen das
grundwasser des ivenacker sees an der
richtige baum am richtigen standort so
könnte gerade die eiche auch dem
klimawandel trotzen
ich weiß ich einfach weiter
bodenschichten erschließen kann
durch ein starkes wurzelsystem gut im
boden verankert ist gegen stürme
gewappnet ist also insofern hat diese
baumart weiterhin eine gute zukunft bei
uns die ivenacker eichen haben offenbar
aber auch noch außergewöhnliche
fähigkeiten sie passen einen teil ihrer
blätter dem klima an
herausgefunden hat das gerade baum
forscher andreas rohloff er entdeckte
auf der sonnenseite andere blätter als
im schatten wenn dann die blätter auf
der südseite eben mit herrchen auf der
blattunterseite einen besseren
trockenheit schutz haben dann werden
diese blätter besser überleben und das
könnte sich über 500 jahre immer weiter
spezialisiert haben auf diese
trockenheit und die feuchtere und
beschaffungsseite und das wäre natürlich
eine sensation wenn sich bestätigt
unterschiedliche blätter an ein und
demselben baum
erstaunlich anpassungsfähig zeigen sich
die ivenacker eichen auch nach 1000
jahren die haut so schnell nichts um
die weisheit der alten es lohnt sich auf
sie zu hören so wir sagen danke fürs
interesse und sie können sich freuen auf
ein spannendes zdf-programm nach uns
fußballsommer mutationen maybrit illner
geht gleich der frage nach wie groß
bleibt das korps ohne risiko und dann
bringt sie unsere kollegin gundula gause
auf den neuesten stand der dinge
die begrüßung kurz nach halb eins im
heute-journal update schönen abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die unwetterserie
nimmt erst zum wochenende ab also dann
gibt es erst mal längere zeit zu
trockenes wetter aber zunächst einmal in
den nächsten stunden also in dieser
nacht ziemlich viel regen im süden
deutschlands und auch noch heftige
gewitter
dieses bild hier ist vom nachmittag und
sie sehen hier wie die gewitter hierauf
geblockt sind teilweise waren es richtig
heftige gewitter auch im unwetter
bereich wie popcorn schießen die
gewitter hier in die höhe
man sieht es hier ganz eindrücklich
weiter im norden gibt es trockene luft
und dementsprechend gibt es dort keine
gewitter schauen wir mal ganz aktuell
auf den radar filme und sie sehen hier
ist einiges an schauern und gewittern
aufgezogen ja und aktuell ist es vor
allem nach westen hin etwas heftiger da
sind doch einige gewitter unterwegs
ansonsten aber auch am oberrhein das
sehen wir vor allem hier ganz gut hier
im südwesten also noch einige schauer
und gewitter die lasse allmählich nach
im süden da werden die gewitter
allmählich in regen übergehen es wird
nicht mehr ganz so heftig werden in der
zweiten nachthälfte die temperaturen
sinken dabei auf 7 grad im nordwesten
und 15 grad zum beispiel richtung bayern
morgen im tagesverlauf wird es im norden
trocken sein
von der ostsee bis ins emsland immer
wieder sonnenschein aber je weiter man
nach süden schaut desto mehr wolken sind
dabei und heftige gewitter das unwetter
tief was heute die gewitter gebracht hat
wütet morgen noch einmal es wird zwar
nicht so heftig wie heute aber trotzdem
nochmal unwetter mit hagel platzregen
und sturmböen dabei und das bei
temperaturen bis 24 grad im osten
deutschlands und 18 grad an den alpen
die kommenden tage am samstag einzelne
gewitter im osten bis 26 grad sonntag
trocken bis 30 und montag erreichte uns
von westen eine kaltfront mit neun
schauern und gewittern und damit wünsche
ich ihnen einen schönen abend